when you think about um
the industry at large one of the things
that comes up a lot is regulation
obviously we're seeing it in all
different forms and fashion some of it
seems to be a tailwind some of it seems
to be a headwind how do you talk to
legacy
kind of market investors people who
think about regulation a lot want uh to
understand that their certainty from a
regulation standpoint what are those
conversations about
yeah i think
the one thing that i try to you know
make very clear to the lps
um is that crypto
is a
you know is a global business
bitcoin ethereum it's global all the the
things popping up in the ecosystem it's
global and if you look at total world
volume
uh spot and futures i think the us is 10
of world volume so i keep telling people
listen stop telling me about the sec and
the treasury and all this stuff i get it
yeah the us is going slow
they're putting speed bumps out there i
personally am not so sure they they know
what they're doing
um they'll figure it out uh they'll
figure it out but
for the investments that we're making
they're all global businesses
and some of them are us but we have some
you know we have a non-regulated
business in there but he's buttoned up
he's smart he's not doing any he's doing
his kyc we're not you know concerned um
about like any
issues it's just that he doesn't operate
in the united states and that's fine
again people in the u.s think everything
is always just about the us and in the
last 30 40 years and before
really since the war i guess that's been
true
um
but
you know
this may be the first time that from a
technology innovation and financial
innovation perspective the us is
definitely not in the lead
and it could be you know i think that
this is an opportunity i've been saying
this for two years
for the legislators here for people in
government
dig deep understand what's going on here
and my goodness i mean incentivize
innovation forget about like over
regulating it and being difficult and
clamping down and all of this stuff
um this is the future and we don't want
to be left behind
and you know i tell my lps these are
these companies they're diversified
globally
um you know even the us ones so
i just
you know i i think it takes a little bit
of time for people to understand that um
i mean just think about how many you
know there are probably node operators
in every country that exists in the
world right
of course you can't say that about other
assets
of course
i've got my brother john here he's got a
couple questions for you
yeah hey dan thank you for doing this
it's really nice to meet you john um 10t
is an awesome name by the way 10t
holdings i love that
well it's only awesome if we're right
that is true that is true um so i'm
curious about you were talking about
investing in the infrastructure of kind
of the digital asset economy what
excites you the most about that so i've
seen that you guys have done investments
in the kraken ledger sas um like what is
exciting to you about it is it the
lightning network is it the hardware is
it kind of the um the exchanges like
what are you excited about moving
forward
yeah i mean you know i take a little bit
of a pedestrian uh approach to it in the
sense that
you know what excites me about the
businesses we're buying
is the fact that they're making a lot of
money
right i'm an investor
okay and the guys who are winning and
know how to win and know how to build
businesses
um those are the guys i want to invest
in that's different from you know
projects that i think are cool
that i think could work
um again i'm not a venture capitalist i
i i don't have the ability to
make skilled judgments about you know
these budding enterprises um you know
in a sense
you know i'm letting
in a way i'm not letting but i'm i'm not
making these investments at c or in the
a rounds
uh or really even b i mean we're usually
focused on b plus and c and d
uh i don't mind paying a higher
valuation
um you know a higher market valuation
if the company has established itself
already um
you know because
the space is growing so quickly
um
i i just as i said i'm just trying to
build a broad diversified
um
bet for
um you know for the traditional investor
and i'll tell you you look at the list
of companies for rlp based i mean most
of them have never heard of these
businesses before so just think about
that never
and
so that's why i say i think we've we've
tapped into a a whole new
uh type of investor base
um
yeah and i mean so i again
the the criteria really is this
threshold
um you know do they have a
you know are they are it's not not a
business looking for a business right
it's a business that's already
established itself and is dominant in
its space
dan when you think about uh moving
forward are you going to just continue
to
allocate capital to the space uh do you
think it's something where once you get
the money invested then you'll kind of
sit and harvest it how do you think
about kind of future plans
yeah i mean i think look if there are
opportunities out there reasonable
evaluations i think we'll keep going in
in some form or another i mean
um you know if i if i look out and there
aren't
opportunities or everything is trading
at 30 40 times revenue then i think that
would you know we take we take a rest
um
but as i said i mean just think about it
one year ago
20 businesses worth over a billion
dollars today there are 70 and that's
not that's not just multiple expansion
and in some cases you know that's
massive revenue expansion
and so you know just
in very like simple terms i mean we all
know the volume just the volume at the
exchanges is up 5x from last year i mean
that's 500 percent
and so there are huge knock-on effects
as the number of wallets increase as
adoption increases
um it's really it's it's exponential and
so as long as there are opportunities
out there i think we'll continue to
allocate capital what's up guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today if we're gonna
be the best business show we obviously
need the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]